ملامح حرب تجاريه تلوح في افق العلاقات
الامريكيه الاوروبيه لتحول الحلفاء الى
خصوم في سوق الطاقه المتخلف لكن السبب
يعود الى تداعيات الحرب الاوكرانيه التي
عززت هذا التنافس المحموم ودفعت اوروبا
لوصف اداره بيض بانها المستفيد الاكبر من
الحرب متهمه اياها بجني الثروات نتيجه
مبيعات الغاز وباسعار مضاعفات اضافه الى
مبيعات السلاح والذخيره بحسب مجله
بوليتيكو الامريكيه غضب والسياء اوروبي
عكسه قبل اسابيع تصريح الرئيس الفرنسي
الذي لم يتعافى من خساره صفقه الغواصات مع
استراليا لالصالح غواصه امريكيه نوويه
الدفع
[موسيقى]
لكن اوروبا التي هربت من مصيده الاعتماد
على الغاز الروسي وقعت في فخ الاسعار
الامريكيه ازمه فاطمه
مع الشتاء او قبله تعاني ايضا اوروبا
والعالم بشكل عام من موجه تضخم كبيره لكن
اكبر نقطه التوتر بين ضيفتي الاطلسي تمثلت
في الاعانات والضرائب الخضراء التي يحددها
بيض خصوصا ان بلدان اوروبيه كثيره عادت
الى الاعتماد على الفحم الحجري نهج يراه
الاتحاد الاوروبي سببا في فقدان التوازن
في الميزان التجاري بشكل غير عادل ويهدد
بتدمير الصناعات الاوروبيه لكن لواشنطن
وجهه نظر تخالف مسار شكاوى الحلفاء
الاوروبيين وتعذر ارتفاع اسعار الغاز الى
الحرب التي شناها في فبراير الرئيس الروسي
على اوكرانيا مستنده في حجتها الى ارتفاع
صادرات الغاز الطبيعيه المسال نحو اوروبا
من 28% الى 45% لكن وعبر هذه الفجوه بين
الحنيفين يسعى الكرملين الى الاستفاده من
ورقه الطاقه والغذاء ايضا مجددا
رهانه على نفس اوروبي قصير في هذه الحرب
الطويله على الجميع